nous sommes une organisation donc
présente surtout en afrique de l'ouest
aussi dans les antilles particulièrement
en haïti où nous avons comme principale
activité la sensibilisation à toutes les
grandes questions environnementales et
en particulier la désertification qui
ravage une grande partie de notre
planète nous avons planté depuis plus de
trente ans donc plus que 100 millions
d'arbres
je répète ce chiffre parce que c'est
quand même impressionnant 100 millions
d'arbres plantés par la jeunesse pour et
par les jeunes pour pouvoir se
construire un avenir de leurs propres
mains nous avons comme objectif aussi de
créer des jardins communautaires qui
soit accessible à la jeunesse prof des
écoles proches des habitations un peu
partout pour tranquillement avoir une
autonomie alimentaire au niveau au moins
des fruits et légumes de base nous
faisons aussi beaucoup d'activités de
recyclage l'apprentissage donc du tri
sélectif du carton du papier du verre
etc
pour arriver à les réutiliser alors
c'est la journée mondiale aujourd'hui de
l'environnement est ce que la planète a
avancé alors la planète avance toujours
d'une certaine façon puisque nous sommes
en mouvement perpétuel comme disent les
traditions amérindiennes dont je fais
partie
mais on peut constater certains reculs
malheureusement aussi du côté surtout du
déboisement des grandes zones d'amazonie
qui sont encore aujourd'hui des boisés
pour d installer des cultures de
d'élevage intensif et la désertification
je dirais galopante et effrayante des
déserts d'afrique qui sont je dirais
très très impressionnant
il est important aujourd'hui comme
toujours d'être conscients que notre
planète est en changement perpétuel et
que nous devons chacun à notre façon
participé pour la reboiser il en va de
nos de notre responsabilité pour les
générations futures
par ailleurs vous êtes vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure
amérindiens d'origine micmacs vous êtes
le des ambassadeurs sur le plan
international oui donc j'ai la chance de
pouvoir représenter cette culture avec
d'autres personnes je ne suis pas le
seul et ça me fait grand plaisir surtout
dans les moments comme maintenant de
pouvoir avec une certaine couleur
représente et s'écoute ces cultures qui
sont pour moi fondamental car nous
devons je dirais vivre dans un monde de
mosaïque de toutes les couleurs afin de
pouvoir connaître les richesses de
chacun je pense qu'à notre époque c'est
indispensable et que ça va et que ça
rime avec l'environnement si on aurait
seulement une seule plante ou un seul
arbre ça serait bien triste
donc je pense que pour l'humanité c'est
la même chose nous avons besoin d'ouvrir
nos cultures ouvrir nos têtes nous
servons nos coeurs à toutes les cultures
du monde et sont imprégnés et partager
donc c'est dans cet esprit là que je
vous parle aujourd'hui avec mes mais à
part à amérindiens